Rein mathematisch gesehen und auf den Einsteinschen
Gleichungen müsste es nicht nur schwarze
sondern auch sogenannte “ Weiße Löcher
“ geben.
Vereinfacht gesagt das komplette Gegenteil
von Schwarzen Löchern: NICHTS kann in das
Weiße Loch gelangen; Strahlung und Materie
können nur abgegeben werden - nichts führt
in die andere Richtung.
Doch bisher konnten Astronomen solche Objekte
noch nie beobachten.
Wie genau kann man sich Weiße Löcher vorstellen
und was haben sie mit Wurmlöchern zu tun?
Herzlich willkommen bei Clixoom Science & Fiction!
Hier gibt es täglich Science Videos mit extrem
spannenden Themen.
Abonniert den Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts.
Los geht’s
Und vielen Dank für diesen coolen Themenvorschlag,
der aus Eurer Whats App Community kam..
Albert Einsteins Allgemeine Relativitätstheorie
hat Schwarze Löcher als direktes Ergebnis.
Denn seine Gleichungen beschreiben, wie sich
Raumzeit in Anwesenheit von Massen verhält.
Vereinfacht gesagt wird die Raumzeit extrem
stark gekrümmt, sobald sich viel Masse auf
wenig Raum konzentriert.
Nichts kann dann mehr aus der Nähe dieser
Masse entkommen - alles muss dort, hinter
diesem sogenannten Ereignishorizont, bleiben.
Selbst Licht!
Eine längere Zeit dachte man, dass diese
mathematischen Lösungen nur theoretisch seien.
Selbst Einstein hielt Schwarze Löcher für
unmöglich.
Bis dann Schwarze Löcher tatsächlich entdeckt
wurden.
Beispielsweise, wenn sie aus dem Kollaps normaler
Sterne entstehen.
Einsteins Gleichungen lassen aber auch noch
andere Lösungen zu - und das sind die der
Weißen Löcher.
Weiße Löcher sind also mathematisch gesehen
absolut gültige Lösungen der Einsteinschen
Gleichungen.
Doch was heißt das konkret?
Auch ein Weißes Loch hat einen Ereignishorizont;
allerdings genau gegenteilig zum Schwarzen
Loch.
Es verschluckt Materie und Strahlung und gibt
nichts davon wieder her.
Als eine Umkehrung des Schwarzen Loches hat
es die Eigenschaft, dass Strahlung und Materie
ständig herausfließen würde.
Nichts davon könnte in sein Inneres gelangen.
Schon seit längerer Zeit beschäftigen sich
Forschungsteams weltweit auch mit Weißen
Löchern; doch bisher blieben sie immer im
Schatten ihrer “großen Brüder” - den
Schwarzen Löchern. 2014 gab es beispielsweise
eine Arbeit zu dem Thema: Demnach könnte
ein Weißes Loch aus einem Schwarzen Loch
entstehen - und zwar durch einen sogenannten
“Quantum Bounce”.
Quantengravitative Effekte würden demnach
dafür sorgen, dass ein Schwarzes Loch kurz
nach seiner Entstehung in sich zusammenfällt
und quasi “zurückprallt”.
Durch diesen Quantum Bounce entstünde dann
aus dem Schwarzen ein Weißes Loch, das explodiert
und verschwindet.
Ähnlich wie bei einer Supernova.
Die Arbeit der beiden US-Physiker ist in Fachkreisen
allerdings umstritten.
Doch es gibt auch Spekulationen, die beiden
Phänomene - also Schwarze und Weiße Löcher
- kombinieren.
Denn der Allgemeinen Relativitätstheorie
zufolge ist es möglich, Raumzeiten “aneinanderzukleben”.
Man kann also theoretisch ein System aus einem
Weißen Loch und einem Schwarzen Loch bauen.
Das wird in der theoretischen Physik dann
“Wurmloch” oder auch “Einstein-Rosen-Brücke”
genannt.
Und das wäre tatsächlich sehr abenteuerlich:
Denn es würde auf der einen Seite der Raumzeit
Strahlung und Materie verschlucken, dann durch
einen Raumzeit Kanal transportieren und auf
der anderen Seite wieder ausstoßen.
Ein Kanal quasi zwischen Universen oder flachen
Raumzeiten!
Doch so erstrebenswert wäre eine solche Reise
durch das Wurmloch gar nicht: Enorme Kräfte
würden alles zerreißen und zerquetschen!
Wenn man den theoretischen Berechnungen Glauben
schenken kann, wäre der Kanal auch nur äußerst
kurz stabil und würde dann wieder verschwinden.
Wenn wir Menschen eine Reise durch solch ein
Wurmloch wagen würde, wäre dies eine Reise
ins Ungewisse - sehr wahrscheinlich in den
Tod.
Bisher lief die Fahndung nach Weißen Löchern
aber auch ergebnislos - kein bislang beobachtetes
Objekt machte den Anschein, als würde es
sich um ein Weißes Loch handeln.
Dabei sollten sie viel deutlicher zu erkennen
sein als ihre dunklen Verwandten.
Und natürlich muss nicht jede mathematische
Lösung auch eine reale Entsprechung haben.
Heißt also konkret: Obwohl sie keinen Widerspruch
zur Relativitätstheorie darstellen, muss
es sie nicht unbedingt auch in Echt geben.
Auf der anderen Seite hat man wie gesagt auch
bei Schwarzen Löchern lange an ihrer Existenz
gezweifelt.
Und auch erst deutlich später festgestellt,
dass es sie nicht nur auf dem Blatt, sondern
auch in der Realität gibt.
Was jedoch dagegen spricht: Bislang ist uns
kein Mechanismus bekannt, durch den ein Weißes
Loch entstehen könnte.
Zudem gibt es auch einen Widerspruch zum zweiten
Hauptsatz der Thermodynamik, nach der die
Entropie im Universum nur gleich bleiben kann
oder aber zunimmt.
Dennoch: Komplett ausgeschlossen ist die Existenz
von Weißen Löchern auf keinen Fall.
Denn wenn wir ehrlich sind, sind wir noch
gar nicht umfassend in der Lage, extreme Zustände
wie in einem Schwarzen oder Weißen Loch zu
beschreiben.
Hierzu müsste man zunächst einmal das Puzzle-Stück
zwischen Gravitation und Quantenmechanik finden
und eine Theorie aufstellen, in der wir beide
vereinen können.
Spätestens dann würden wir sicherlich auch
neue Erkenntnisse über Weiße Löcher bekommen....
Wenn es die gibt, dann erfahrt ihr es natürlich
hier mit zuerst, abonniert dafür den englischen
Kanal, dafür hier klicken, denn auch da gibt
es Videopremieren, wie zum Beispiel diese:
How dangerous are solar storms?
Dafür hier klicken.
Ich freue mich auf euch auch auf dem englischen
Kanal.
See you soon, stay tuned!